my wife likes to tell people that he
looks very nice he's a very nice guy
he's a very calm guy
but he has a dark side to it
as a thriller writer my job is to look
out into the real world see the problem
side i create the problems then during
the course of the novel i solve them
you don't want the reader to sort of
settle back and be really comfortable
and like drifting through these pages
you want to grab them by the throat
right from the get-go and hurdle them
through the next 450 pages
i wanted to get into the weeds with all
of you about how i go about my craft
great characters how do you come up with
them how do you pace the story
so that people can't stop turning the
pages all the things that go into
making a successful writing career i've
tried to deliver to you during this
master class
i was a lawyer when i first started
writing my first novel i would spend
time with my family
they would go off to bed and around 10
o'clock i would go downstairs and i
would write till 2 in the morning
every day seven days a week and i did
that for years if you want to be
creative writing stories
you have to be very creative in finding
the time to write those stories
research for me is critical this binder
is
my nuke binder the section i'm going to
read to you is about
two and a half pages long two and a half
pages versus
this do this leave almost all of it out
you will thank me later
i had insecurities you will have
insecurities so any writer out there
who's doubting their ability to actually
sit down and tell a story
i'm telling you i got your back on this
writers change the world
books change the world as much as you
might need a class from me
i and the rest of the publishing world
and the world in general
we need you a lot more
i'm david baldacci and this is my master
class
you